it's ESPN I think people who don't know
Pascal see Ockham's game might have been
a little bit surprised to see him score
32 points in his first ever NBA Finals
appearance what was it about who he is
and what he's got that allowed him to
perform on this stage that well he does
a great job of attacking those gaps
using his body attacking the angles that
the different is giving you he can go
both ways I just like when he plays that
aggressive but given his improbable
background and his lack of experience in
this game you played a game of
basketball you know you know whatever
happened in the past happened you know I
think having the mindset of going for it
and knowing there's gonna be okay your
teammates have your back demons believe
in you that's all it matters and he
knows that all rows back in the middle
Kayla Marc Kayla great TSN I mean you've
always been one to look for an extra
pass but in this game you're a little
bit more comfortable with going for that
three and a lot of the other guys as
well was there something that opened up
for you guys maybe extra passes that
open things up in terms of good looks it
seemed as though that worked for you
guys on offense they were blitzing Kawai
on a pick-and-roll and and allowing you
know the middle floor open or they were
switching early on they're you know the
the off end and we did a good job of
moving that ball and finding I thought I
still think we can do a better job on it
but you know that was good enough and I
still think that we can do a much better
job defensively that we did tonight on
stretches I thought the second half we
improved our rebounding and we didn't
allow I think as many second-chance
points as we did in the first half so
overall happy left side row Steve Steve
Ashburn at nba.com Steve Kerr labelled
them
as dare shots opportunities you had
where they didn't rotate to you and you
had basically uncontested shots on do
they feel like you're being dared to
make those kind of shots and how does
making those versus not making those
early in a game affect your game as it
goes on if you open you get a shoot them
you know they're no they're like you
open you shoot them you know and then we
go from there
we've bigger win great if now you keep
taking them with confidence right side
fit throw a mark Dan working with the
Los Angeles Times you played a lot of
big games in your career but you've
never been on this stage but were there
moments tonight where we were able even
for a blank able to reflect and be like
I'm in the NBA Finals and what was that
like personally for you to be able to be
on this thing no my brain doesn't
function that way you know you out there
you playing basketball like you did your
whole live and you know this kind of you
know whether it's the most fun you are
locking not allow you know there when
they make a couple shots a tough shot or
mistakes that you made offensively kind
of rattled you a little bit and
frustrate you you're gonna you know stay
poised during the whole game so your
brain can go anywhere else but but you
know every possession last question on
the left side for throw my mark Michael
Grange from Sports Net what you said
when you notice early that they are
gonna be very aggressive trapping
sending a second defender at Kauai what
what how does your brain function at
that point what signal gets sent to you
well we were we if you watched the
previous series against Portland they
you know they did that with Emily Lauren
and CJ so we assumed that there was a
chance we're gonna play it's Kauai so we
were you know understanding the spacing
that we were gonna have and what kind of
shot we're gonna be open what kind of
rotations they were gonna do now you
know we we gotta still improve in some
areas and spacing and moving out of that
down
overall I thought we did a decent job
did were you conscious of trying when
they did switch trying to take a smaller
guy down to the rim a little bit more
than you haven't previously in the
playoffs yeah I know you know I thought
that uh the guys did a good job of
finding me in the post the you know the
two or three times that I went down
there and it went well thank you Mark